Hello, Tristan, and welcome to FOSSDA!
I'd like to start by just asking
you to introduce yourself and tell us
a little bit about yourself.
Okay so, my name is Tristan Nitot.
I pronounce it the French way because
I'm a French citizen.
I am 55.
I was born in Paris' suburbs and
I live in Paris.
And I have been involved with computers
since I was 14.
I think that was in 1980 or
is it...'81?
I can't remember exactly.
But for some reason, a friend of
my parents' bought a TRS-80, a Tandy
RadioShack, that, you know, made it to
France somehow back then and thought 'oh,
the young Tristan may be interested in
this new thing'.
And so, he was going on vacation
for two weeks and so, before going
to vacation, he dropped it at the
house - which was at the time
in Normandy, in rural, very rural Normandy,
in the middle of nowhere - and
for 15 days in a row, I
was stuck in front of it.
You know, opening the manual page 1
and starting to read and it was
very exciting.
I can't remember whether it was in
French or in English, but I started
learning how to program computers with the
BASIC language there, and it was like
a tiny door open to a new
world that grown ups did not understand
at all.
So, that made me very special and
so, it made the world very exciting,
you know, learning new things where no
one around me could compete with, you
know, because being a kid known in
the place - my parents are wonderful
- but it was nice to be
the one that knows the most about
something.
And that's how I got into computing
and programming at the time.
And then my parents, a bit later,
moved to Paris, where I got the
opportunity that- there was something here, in
Paris, that got started, we call it
the CMI.
In French, CMIE , Centre Mondial Informatique
which means, like, Worldwide Center for Computing,
which sounds a bit over the top,
if you ask me, but still.
And it was a very special place
which welcomed computer scientists and also biology
researchers from the MIT mostly.
And in France, where they had, like,
a gorgeous building right in the middle
of Paris, the Elysee Palace, which is
our French House, French White House.
You could actually see the French White
House from from the building itself.
And the ground floor was open to
the general public.
And I was one of these kids
who could use computers, you know, to
show up early in the morning, make
sure that you would be the first
to be sitting in front of the
computer.
And a whole community started there, you
know, people from all walks of life
happened to be there and started chatting
and discussing computer stuff and learning stuff
and teaching each other stuff because there
was that bunch of computers left in
front of them.
We were supposed to learn how to
program in Logo, that's a programming language.
I think the creator of it was
Seymour Papert from MIT, if I recall
correctly.
But, you know, in some cases, we
were illegally copying some games on diskettes
and stuff like that.
So it was not- we were not
exactly doing what we were supposed to
do, not all of us at least.
When I started learning how to program
computers in Assembly Language, this is where
I first met my well, the Apple
2 computer, which was very exciting.
And somehow there were a couple of
terminals left in the room that nobody
was using because they were meant for,
you know, the organizers of the place,
yet to log in and of course,
I didn't have a password.
But somehow, a few friends of mine
managed to hack into the computers and
into these terminals and got noticed, well,
caught, I don't know.
But they were nice enough to say
oh, you seem to be, you know,
doing pretty well with these things so
why don't we open up an account
for you.
And so, a bunch of us were
authorized to use the the mainframe computer
that they had on top of the,
you know, everything that the Apple 2s
and the other personal computers around there.
It was- I think it was in
'82 or '83 or something.
1982-1983, like that.
And there was one guy that I
met there who had a long beard
and long hair and whose name is
Richard M.
Stallman.
So, I met this guy.
He was just, you know, an ordinary
guy.
More hairy than most, but still.
And so, we were learning different things,
you know, we were able to use
the various computers that are there.
And so we were- there were like
a handful of kids, like me, that
were allowed to go into the corridors,
into the upper floors and use not
just the Apple 2s and the rest
that wasn't it on the ground floor,
but something else all they had.
It was tons of fun, we were
learning a lot.
And it happens that, in retrospect, this
is where a lot of the IT
or startup generations started in France.
A bunch of these kids, including myself,
well, became involved in computing for the
rest of their lives and started companies
and stuff.
I don't know if you should be
asking me questions, or should I keep
going or?
Well, I'm happy to.
So, you met Mr.
Stallman and at that time, were you
thinking about free software or open source,
or was this before that time?
When did those ideas sort of start
percolating into your world?
It was- at first, I was a
kid so a lot of things were
not clear in my head like what's
allowed and what's not allowed.
You know, like if you copy software,
can you legally do it or you
just, can you physically do it?
You know, it's just, it's kind of
the same thing more or less.
So, whether I was allowed to do
so or not was not very clear
and therefore, the free software and nature
of things, well, we were sharing whether
it was legal or illegal, by the
way so, you see what I mean.
And at the time, I didn't realize
the importance of it, to be honest,
I'm a bit ashamed in retrospect.
But no, it didn't make any difference
for me.
Fast forward to - when was that?
- 1996.
I had discovered the web, I had
started doing my first web page.
At that time, the big craze was,
you know, having your homepage.
Like, if, when you go on the
web, of course, you start browsing but
there's not a lot to see.
Then the next step is to build
your own home page, so that's what
I did, but I didn't want to
do like everybody else.
And it happened that my wife was
pregnant with our first child.
And so, I decided to build the
home page of our baby which wasn't
born at the time.
So you had to put the, you
know, given name, give your name, put
a picture and have your resume but
in all of these three cases it
was a bit odd.
So, I had to put a picture
- is it a sonogram?
Is that how you call it?
- you know, like, so there was
that picture of the kid, of the
baby's sonogram instead of a mug shot.
And we didn't have a name for
him right away, so we call him
Virtual Bob because - well, people kept
asking 'what's his name?' And I said,
'we'll call him Bob for now' and
so it was Virtual Bob.
And the page is still online, by
the way.
I moved it and it's still on
my website.
And it's mostly in French, some of
it is in English.
So, it was it was fun.
And of course, the craze at the
time was all about Netscape, the web
browser, and also the server-side software.
And I was in a company, a
small French company - sorry, my cat
is misbehaving - and so, that's a
French company that imported software from North
America, Canadian and American, and I was
very excited by the web.
And one day, I was browsing on
the French Netscape website where I saw
a job posting for, like, kind of
an evangelist for Netscape in France.
I said, yeah, I could totally picture
myself being paid for discussing the web
around me and so, I applied and
it took a while because the there
was a hiring freeze at the time
so they left me for three months,
hanging out.
But in nearby, I made it into
Netscape , it was in '97 and
it was a lot of work, but
it was fun with smart people.
In '98, then Netscape decides to open
up the source code for Netscape Communicator.
Right.
And they called it open source, at
the time - I'm sorry, it's taking
me a lot of time to answer
your question - but it was open
source because Eric Raymond named it open
source, he was the guy who was
involved with Netscape management, and it was
more, kind of West Coast, very business-friendly
view of the world.
And so, open source, I think, at
the time, was crafted as a word,
as an expression, as opposed to free
software which was more, I don't know
how you call it left it or
kissed or well, not super business friendly
or where business wouldn't come first, freedom
was would come first.
And so, at the time, it was
open source and I was in France,
I was employed by Netscape for southern
Europe.
And then there was that announcement that
Netscape would give away the browser.
So it was a matter of price.
So everybody got it.
And for that part of the message,
that was easy that price equals 0.
Fine.
Well, not every salesman was happy with
that because they had quotas, and all
of this, so they were wondering 'how
am I going to make money if
the price tag says zero?' They got
it, not really happy but got it.
And then there was that source code
opening and collaboration and then, you know,
nobody got a clear understanding of what
it meant.
A couple of, you know, tech people
in Paris kind of got it but
didn't feel that publishing the code was
good.
Like, nobody cared, like, would the customer
be interested in the code?
Of course not.
I mean, they don't even know what
it means, so you know, so changing
the code- well.
And then there was me.
And I remember, Richard Stallman and I
remembered all of that, that it was
actually, you know, pretty close.
If you zoom out, you know, seeing
from afar, it's very similar.
Now, there are significant differences between open
source and free software, but seen from
afar, they're pretty close.
And I was very excited because it
was a grand idea.
It was something bigger than myself, it
was something that was bigger than just
making money and selling software, it was-
yeah, it was amazingly exciting for reasons
that are hard to explain.
I was not so interested in, you
know, selling software.
That was fine, I mean, making good
money was fine, but it was not
super exciting as opposed to open source
software that once again, was like a
new door was opening, it was amazing.
And I think even for the free
software community, it was a big change
in the sense that before that really,
it was computer scientists getting together and
hacking software in the office and sending
tapes from one place to the other.
Yeah, I'm sorry, I never used tapes
myself.
Well, actually I did on it here
as a, you know, not on that
scale.
I was not sending my piece of
software on tapes to friends, like the
MIT people did at some point.
Uh-huh.
But it was their way to do
things.
And then came a new ingredient, that
was the web, and that completely changed
the cooperation between developers.
Netscape made - well, created - the
Mozilla project and along with it came
Bugzilla.
Uh-huh.
Which was a complete game changer, even
if it was not beautiful and not
super easy to use, it was amazing.
Well, so basically it's a- you could
kind of compare it to GitHub these
days, more or less.
It's an issue tracker but first it
was, you know, it was running in
a web browser.
That means that everyone with a PC,
and a web browser, and an internet
connection, and some understanding of a code,
could start hacking.
And hacking in the sense of, you
know, developing or trying to or playing
with a piece of software, could contribute
to that piece of software.
So, it was a complete game changer,
in the sense that you didn't have
to be in the address book of
a bunch of computer scientists to send
tapes through mail to other people.
You could show up, you know, you
could open a bug.
He just had to open an account
in Bugzilla and you could comment on
bug reports and say 'this is doing
this and I expect that and I
suspect this is coming from that piece
of code' and you started engaging with
the community.
So, the community itself instead of being
a small one, became potentially, a really
big one, provided that the project was
interesting.
And to be honest, the Mozilla project
was not super interesting at the beginning
for many reasons.
First, well, the piece of software was-
there was a lot of friction, you
know, with Bugzilla and all of that;
the tools were rudimentary.
And also, there was something, which is
really bad, is that the source code
that was open was missing very significant
pieces because in a bunch of places
of the communicator code, there were proprietary
list licenses.
So, Netscape couldn't ship the whole thing
and you could compile it and make
it work.
Now, they were willing to ship the
product but they had to remove big
pieces of it.
And so, you end up with a
Swiss cheese instead of the whole thing.
And so, you can compile it, you
can use it.
You know, it was very frustrating, and
also it was huge, and the quality
wasn't great because over the previous years,
the Netscape teams had struggled to compete
with Microsoft and so they rushed features
half-baked into the product in order to
beat the competition and all that.
And so, this leaves them with a
technical debt that was huge.
So you ended up with a terrible
open source experience.
And on top of that, Netscape was
being bought by AOL, America Online.
And maybe in order to help with
the Mozilla project, you had to have
the knowledge to do that.
The willingness to cope with the terrible
experience, and you were willing to give
your precious free time - and as
a computer engineer, you don't have a
lot of this because you're worth a
lot on the market - and on
top of that you were willing to
give this to - what was his
name?
Is it Steve Case?
Uh huh, right.
The CEO of AOL-
AOL, yeah.
The former executive of Pizza Hut, you
know.
And I'm not saying bad things about
him but basically, he's not the kind
of guy that is really appealing to
us or, you know, of two volunteers,
basically.
Are you willing to give your your
time with worth some money and your
energy to someone who's already super rich
by, you know, selling pizza, And so,
it wasn't a great start.
It wasn't a great start for the
Mozilla project and it became worse.
I was, at the time, I managed
to change jobs within Netscape and go
to, at the time it was Netscape
Client Predict Division or Client Product Development.
It was Netscape CPD, but I can't
remember.
Well, you get the gist.
And so, they asked me to do
a job, which was, you know, very
unpleasant, which was - it was an
important job.
Well, important, I don't know, but I
took it seriously, except it wouldn't work.
I was asking web developers to make
sure that their website was compatible with
the upcoming version, the open source version
following Communicator.
First Netscape Communicator, was bleeding market share.
It was terrible with going lower and
lower.
So it was not the hype, it
was not the promising browser and therefore,
people cared less and less about it.
And on top of that, I was
not talking about the current version, I
was talking about the newer version, the
future version, that did not exist at
the time except in beta 15 versions
that nobody used.
And they had nothing to do in
terms of compatibility with the old version.
So, telling people that they should change
their habits, and their products and their
websites to be compatible with something that
wasn't there, you know, just in order
to be future proof and while nobody
really cared about the product and nobody
really believed, and that it had a
future was extremely unpleasant because people wouldn't
listen to me.
So we took the long list of
important websites in the US.
So I had colleagues that did that
in US, and I was doing that
in Germany, France and UK, like the
500, the top 500 websites, in these
three countries.
And we were trying all of them,
the main features, in the upcoming version
of the browser.
And of course, we were writing down
what it failed, we opened bug reports
in Bugzilla to follow up on that
and then we were to analyze their
website syntax and if their HTML and
JavaScript and CSS was broken, how it
was broken, how we could fix it.
And then we came up with a
fix and we sent them, and they
wouldn't care.
Uh huh.
So, this is why it wasn't pleasant.
Trying to fix one one website at
a time, fifteen hundred websites in three
different languages to people who didn't care
at all on the other, and that
wasn't fun.
I think it was important because something
that probably is not clear to people
who maybe will hear or view this
video, it's the new version of Communicator
which was a open source had a
new engine named Gecko, and Gecko was
a complete rewrite of the old Netscape
Communicator engine.
And by complete rewrite means that the
old bugs weren't in the new code
base.
So it was better, but it was
less forgiving for spelling mistakes and such
in-the-web pages, not in the text, but
in the mark-up that made rendering.
And so, it meant that if your
page displayed properly in Internet Explorer, Microsoft
Internet Explorer, or Netscape Communicator cap for
sorry.
Cathy's, a 44 in French, then you
thought you would define, but with the
upcoming version of the Mozilla browser, it
would fail.
Which was frustrating for everybody involved, both
the people that made the websites, that
thought they were good - 'It's rendering
in IE, so I'm fine' - No!
And also the Mozilla developers who had
to replicate Internet Explorer bugs into their
own code for the safety of compatibility,
which is, I'm sure very unpleasant.
Yeah.
And so, this was what we were
doing at a time.
So, this was around 2000 or something.
And in the meantime, AOL didn't understand
a thing about software.
They had their own proprietary system, which
was very different from the web than
their online service, which embedded Internet Explorer
- the competition, you know - and
we were trying to have them include
our piece of software, already ringing engine.
From your own company?
Yes, instead of the competition and they
didn't get why they would do that
because it will be less compatible with
the existing web, than Internet Explorer.
So it was frustrating even for them,
and for us as AOL employees.
It was a very difficult time and
so, they started laying off Netscape employees.
Several waves.
I managed to get through a few
of them, but it was scary like
maybe you're going to get fired next
week and you never know.
And so, well, it wasn't pleasant for
pretty much everyone involved.
And when they, AOL, got enough of
all of this, they were - I
don't know the exact words, I'm sorry,
it's vocabulary I don't use often -
but they were fighting.
It's more of your realm than mine.
You know, they were suing.
They were suing Microsoft basically.
And they got a deal with Microsoft
like 'we'll stop suing you and you
write a nice fat check and we're
good friends now', you know.
Also it's really not good for business,
right?
And so, Microsoft did write a big
fat check to AOL which suddenly lost
- or seem to lost, that's how
I see it - any kind of
interests with Netscape.
Like, 'Okay, got my money.
Why would I care about these hippies
that do open source?'
And so, they kind of gave up
on us and decided to let the
Mozilla project go and pretty much everyone
was laid off.
A few people, you know, being Computer
Engineers could be, you know, move to
other AOL divisions and stuff but most
of the people were laid off which,
it was an unpleasant end to an
unpleasant moment.
And it was frustrating because, I mean,
many people - and I at least,
but I know people around me -
thought that the web was a wonderful
promise.
We hoped that open source would be
the answer to, you know, saving that
promise and make it happen.
And we hoped that AOL having deep
pockets would help us and it didn't
happen.
So, we were disappointed.
And especially, you know, that promise was
not going to be fulfilled - the
promise of the web, you know.
In retrospect, I find myself very naive,
maybe not that- a bit naive.
Hopefully, I'm staying naive, which is good,
I think.
Naive for thinking that the web is
a wonderful thing and even if you
think about Facebook right after that, you'd
understand what I mean by naive, you
know.
But there's a good part of the
web, which is carrying the promise.
And so, we were seeing the moment
where the web was for everyone to
publish, to communicate, and if you communicate,
you understand each other better.
And then you think about Twitter and
realize this is not the case at
all but still.
And so, it was disappointing that this
promise wouldn't happen and we had lost
our job.
The Mozilla Foundation was created in order
to carry the project and-
And this was in the early 2000's,
is that right?
Or...?
Yeah, I think it's mid 2003.
Yeah, okay.
I should have checked my dates before
but I think this is it.
I think that the AOL Microsoft deal
happened in June 2003.
We were laid off in mid-July.
And so what we're going to do,
the Mozilla Foundation which was just created
had the brand- you know, the right
to use the Mozilla Brand, which was,
you know, good at least.
You know, we got it from from
the Netscape folks.
A few machines with the, you know,
servers and stuff with this whole scored
on it and hardware to make it
run.
A bit of cash but it was
like two million dollars.
And not in one payment, in two
payments.
And the code.
And of course, the code, which was
open.
And that was good.
And with the money, they managed to
hire like eight people or something, less
than a dozen of the important folks
in Silicon Valley, which was good.
But for us in Europe, nothing.
Uh-huh.
Well, you have to remember, there were
like, several hundreds Netscape employees working on
the Mozilla project.
So it was like a vast majority
of them got laid off and only
a tiny part was rehired immediately by
the Mozilla Foundation.
And it was a bit gloomy and
we thought we were doomed, and actually
it was the opposite.
Yeah.
In fact, maybe I'm just terrible at
understanding things!
It's never like I think it is!
I thought it was terrible and it
was actually a good thing because we
were able to bounce back, literally, like
hitting the floor and bounce back because
suddenly, we were not in the shadow
of AOL and suddenly we were we
were something important and we were a
bit helpless.
And that meant that some people were
interested in helping us, suddenly.
They wouldn't spend a dime or their
time to help something in the shadows
of AOL but suddenly, you know, if
you feel like you're gonna die, they
wouldn't see and your hand, which is
good.
And so, at the same time it
needs to be said, the Mozilla project
itself had decided - I don't know
how to say that - but it
was very smart, but also unpleasant.
So, before this happened, we were trying
to attract a community of people that
could come and work on the project.
And some of them were individuals and
some of them were professionals, like, IBM
employees, that came to work and which
were contracting with clients, and in between
contracts, they would come and spend some
time working with us.
Well, you know, at least they were
paid by the employer and employer said,
instead of not doing anything with the
client, you should spend your time on
doing this and that on, on the
Mozilla project.
It was good.
But everybody came and left and wanted
to leave their mark on the product.
You know, like you want to do
that button that's, you know, is used
by probably like two percent of the
users but that's really cool.
Like, with this click, you could switch
off all the presentation and you see
the raw page.
Isn't it beautiful if you can do
that?
Like nobody's going to do that anyway,
but it's cool and it's my button!
You see?
It's not mine because I didn't do
that, but I've met many people that
really wanted to have their own button
in the product, or their own feature,
or their menu option or- yeah.
There were fights about what can be
put in a contextual menu when you
right-click on something.
Would be cool if my feature was
there, you know?
Because it's visible and all that.
And so, we were, we were trying
to attract people and at the same
time, it was really hard to keep
the product clean.
And to be honest, it was kind
of becoming a bit bloated because of
that.
And there were a couple of people
who had a very strong opinion about
what a good product would look like.
And that meant the product would have
to be simple.
And also, not every feature deserves to
be argued over and discussed forever.
I haven't really made up my mind
about all of this, you know.
I want people to participate, I want
to give them the UI space so
that there is their button displayed.
At the same time, I know that
ordinary users are overwhelmed with too many
options.
When their contextual menu is two pages
long or dozens of things that pop
in their user interface.
I understand that, but like many people,
I was mad when these couple of
people started to remove user interface objects
from the user interface, you know.
Like this button gone!
This feature gone!
This menu item gone!
And wait, wait, I did it myself,
you know, I had a lot of
hours, put into that thing and you're
basically spitting in my face, you know,
by removing my work.
You're killing my work just because you
decide this isn't cool.
This is not acceptable.
So, there were fights between the willingness
to include a lot of people in
the open source way, and the willingness
to make a clean simplified product.
And then it wasn't pleasant, once again.
It was hard to take off, you
know, make the community, take off and
then there was these couple guys, you
know, killing it.
So, at the time, the two projects
went side-by-side and the clean and simplified
project became Firefox.
But at the time, you have to
understand that Firefox wasn't cool at all
in the community.
Well, it wasn't called Firefox at the
time, but what became Firefox was not
cool because of the way it was
managed.
Which was the right way!
To be honest, if, you know, the
story, the end of the story, of
course they were right to do that.
But it wasn't cool to see them
do that to the open source project,
and to the participation who many of
us wanted to see happening.
And also, it was it was a
matter of power.
They could decide and we could just
see our work removed from the product.
That wasn't cool.
And there were, like, two things they
did that pretended to be nice.
One is 'please don't comment in a
bug reports in Bugzilla, just use the
forums to do that'.
Yeah, go and start a forum thread
about this and so, you could yell
everything you wanted to, they never read
it, I'm sure.
I know!
But I'm pretty sure they didn't read
anything at all.
And if there I weren't in these
shoes, I wouldn't read it, right?
Like I don't read the comments in
the nowadays because I know, it's just
blah.
So they didn't go in places where
they were criticized.
And so they, they pretended the forums
were the right place to discuss removals
of stuff, and then read it.
And the second thing they did, which
was really amazing, was the extension system.
Maybe I'm rewriting history, but I don't
think I am, is that when they
removed the buttons and widgets and stuff
from Firefox - what would became become
Firefox - they said yes, but there
is now an extension mechanism that enables
you to write an extension.
So, if you want your button back,
you write an extension and you could
put back, basically copy paste your code
into the extension - was a bit
of a lie but at least they
had something to respond - so you
put it in the extension and the
extension, you can add it manually into
your instance of the product.
Right.
And extensions have been fantastic for Firefox
precisely because you could customize your browser.
And now all the browsers have them,
right?
Yes.
Exactly!
And now, my current job today is
to write an extension.
I have a company around that which
is funny, pretty much 18 years later.
Well so, you mentioned the end of
the story and I want to make
sure that we get to the end
of the story because I think when
most people think about Firefox at least,
you know, during a period of about,
I don't know ten years or so,
they would probably call it a wild
success.
So to tell me about, you know,
when Firefox launched, and it began to
challenge Internet Explorer and so forth, you
know, what are your thoughts about that?
Well, so in July 2003, I get
laid off and the people in a
European offices, get laid off.
And there is that promise of the
web, you know, which was basically delayed
by Internet Explorer.
Well by Microsoft, not willing to update
Internet Explorer, not being interested in the
future of the web, right?
They were interested in stopping the web
because it was dangerous for the windows
Monopoly.
It was not good for the Microsoft
Office way of selling licenses.
In the, at the time.
You have to remember that it was,
you would buy shrink-wrapped CDs at Fry's
or, you know, a retail store and
the idea of having software delivered to
you.
In a browser that was like super
dangerous to Microsoft business model and it
we've seen it took them years to
build Microsoft 365 and such how this
struggling with Microsoft, with Google Docs and
stuff competing with Google.
And so, to some extent, they were
right and I don't think they were
on there.
They weren't on the good side of
the moral story, but at least business
ways, they were, right.
But now that the web was stalling,
they were not interested in, you know,
making a modern browser and all of
that and so it was somebody else's
job to do it.
Except that there was no money to
be made.
You know with browser, because Internet Explorer
was still shipping with Windows and you
would get you know, what's the price
tag was set to zero forever.
And then so nobody who would be
interested in competing with with a product
with no money to be made in
a process.
So it was more or less mozilla's
job to make it happen.
And Mozilla was at a stop, you
know, so we decided and a couple
of friends and myself and a couple
of people and new volunteered in the
community in Italy, in Poland in the
UK, in France, and Germany.
We loved the Mozilla project.
We knew that standalone browser, which became
Firefox was in the pipes, you know,
being worked on.
Some of us, well, we ended up
everyone everyone understanding, it would work, but
we didn't realize all of us at
the same time, you know, it was
it happen over time, but "I think
that that Firefox thing is, maybe it's
going to take off.
Maybe it's going to work." And so,
even if I don't have a job.
I'm going to help make it well
to life.
I will help delivering it to the
world.
We thought it would be in a
few months, so it was like a
over a few months and the French
law saying, you can't lay off someone
for at least three months.
This, you get at least three months
severance.
And then you have an employment benefits
that there is a small period of
time where you don't have anything but
I was doing okay, so I thought
I'm going to do that in the
meantime, so I'm going to help the
Mozilla Foundation to serve potential users in
Europe because I knew from experience that
it's really hard for a U.S.
organization to properly deliver an address users
and clients and customers in Europe because
it's so different.
It's so many well two cultures being
different languages being different, the need for
localization, you know, translating piece of software
making sure, quality assurance in the languages
is properly done, and all of that.
It's complicated when you're Netscape.
It's a bit easier when you are
AOL, because you have more money, but
if your Mozilla foundation with eight employees,
not going to happen for sure.
And I thought who could do that
in Europe and, and like everybody, I
would talk to the old said, well
Tristan, You're the guy.
Come on, I don't want to do
that.
I don't feel like I'm properly equipped
to, to do that.
You know, and so anyway, I would
gather people from different countries.
People that I knew that were involved
in helping the Mozilla project in and
we decided we would make an organization
to support that too.
Make it real.
And I ask who, well we need
if it's a French non-profit.
We need a president.
That's the name of the job position
who who wants to be president and
I didn't want to be present at
all like and that's just that something
happier than they ask for a volunteer
and everybody steps back once except one.
That was me.
You know, that's why I got, I
got involved.
In this, but they were right.
It kind of makes sense, you know,
maybe it was because I was at
the least technical of all of them.
So what was put in a place
where I would do the less damage
and and so we we did that,
hoping that Firefox would launch soon.
Unfortunately.
It took us.
I think 10 or 15 months to
launch because it's software and that never
happens on time and it which was
a lot longer that I expected.
And that was not easy at all
to do that because you know, that
like the the French an employment agency
was asking me whether I would sending
resumes and, you know, and stuff like
that or whether I was creating a
company, and I was not creating a
company, you know.
These are the two options, basically and
then they were threatened to stop the
benefits from coming.
And I managed to be lucky enough
to be discussing with a guy who
was nice and an understanding and said,
so you're building a non-profit?
"Yes, and we're going to crush Microsoft!"
and yeah, yeah, sure.
But and so, I would, I would
show him.
Emails from Mitchell Baker and from the
Mozilla foundation and stuff like that.
He wouldn't speak a word of English
as a translate me.
So I could have, you know,
You could have said anything?
Anything, but I did not.
I was I was so yes, we
were discussing, you know, so that we
could use the Mozilla brand and and
stuff like that.
And he said, "yeah, sure it's fine."
And in the end we ended up
creating.
hundreds of jobs in Europe, so it's
so he was right, but at the
time it was a bit far-fetched to
to believe me and believe that I
would we succeed.
And so, Firefox was making progress at
the same same time.
And even before it reached 1.0 as
a version, even by 0.8., It was,
it was, it was crazy.
People would adopt it.
People would promote it.
It would, it was the next cool
thing.
I was spending, probably a third of
my time blogging about it and talking.
I remember in a cafe in Paris,
there were two guys in the next
table who were discussing the web.
I remember, chatting, "Have you heard that
Firefox?" You know, like they were this
guy?
No, never heard.
Well, you should try to know it's
fun and it works.
It really worked!
And then the people in the UK
and the Lance Poland, Italy, Germany, and
France, they will be doing all the
same.
And and to be honest it was
it was almost too easy because the
web developer were so Upset by Internet
Explorer.
What was a really terrible browser?
Like very, very buggy with full of
security holes and let me get past
and even if you broke proper HTML,
it wouldn't displayed properly and stuff like
that.
And sothey were waiting for An alternative,
a better solution and and Firefox was
well, could be, and it showed that
it started to be the response to
that.
It was, it was delivering, really.
It wasn't perfect at all.
But in many cases, in many things,
we were better than Internet Explorer, and
we were showing constant improvement, newer versions,
and it was cool.
It was op.
We were discussing web standards.
So, you knowor what we call sometimes
the quality web like the web done
properly as we could make it, maybe
an industry, you know, something serious.
Not just working around Internet Explorer bugs,
but really make it proper decent job.
Yeah, make the web nice make it,
make it good and also open source.
You know, David versus Goliath.
It was crazy.
You know that the Mozilla foundation in
Mozilla Europe.
Both on profits were kicking Microsoft ass.
It didn't seem possible, but it was
happening and so people got excited.
It.
Was that "Spread Firefox" campaign going on,
where people were putting buttons to spread
Firefox and they were counters and so
they would compete to bring the most
downloads and stuff like that and there
was a need., obviously there was a
need for a better web browser with
with tabs with extensions with support for
the newest CSS features and also fast
because it was completely rewritten and you
know.
It was, it was really cool.
Basically, it became viral.
I would say.
And so I stayed there, making sure
that we would launch Firefox in Europe,
probably even though I was kind of
starving financially, but I made the commitment
that I would help shape Firefox 10,
and the unemployment agency was kind enough
to let me do it, even though
the unemployment benefits are as good as
a, as a real paycheck.
It's still, it's still Money.
So we made it work.
It was, it was really, it was
really cool.
And it was, it was amazing.
I think that the open source movement
was also behind us, you know.
It was really two things, the web
standards and web development.
So web standards were hope for the
forward-thinking web developers for some web developers.
That was, you know, one of these,
you know things, one more thing to
think about but some people were forward-thinking
enough to understand that maybe this is
going to be your job, easier, down
the road and be better considerated, and
you know, instead of dealing with bugs,
but rather than dealing with features and
you know, interesting stuff.
And also the open-source movement where they
were was a lot of hope that
the Microsofts of the world would be
replaced when they were in either with
something that was caring more about individuals.
And so these two forces were helping
us pushing us, and we were and
then and the product was was in
perfect position.
It was really good.
It was, it was really good.
It wouldn't have happened if it was
crap, and it was not no, I
mean it.
Easy to make promises, but if you
don't deliver people notice and we'll come
back, and frankly we were competitive.
While iut depends when.
But at the beginning, we were barely
competitive.
We were competitive on some things and
some not at all.
So you have to carefully pick what
you would demo.
This brings me back to a moment.
I was still with Netscape.
I Invited as a Netscape employee to
deliver a talk about open source at
a conference in Paris.
And I was demoing.
So it was a bit bizarre was
in the early days of the Netscape,
well, the Mozilla project hosted by Netscape.
It was the Gecko rendering engine.
It was pretty much the only thing
we had at the moment that would
that worked.
And it was shipping in the proprietary,
Netscape Communicator user interface.
So when you looked at it you
thought it was Netscape Communicator, except inside
the engine was Gecko and I did
my slides with PowerPoint and exported to
HTML and showed these in that Frankenstein
version of a browser.
And so I explained how we do
this and that at Mozilla and Netscape
and blah, blah, blah.
And at the end, I said, by
the way, you've seen Gecko running all
along all that you've seen in that
square part of the screen of the
browser window was actually open source.
People were suddenly excited like you see,
they thought they were just, you know,
viewing slides by some marketing guy /
moron, or you know.
But still they were seeing open source
in action and then I did demos
where I picked at it.
Side-by-side demos of Netscape communicator and that
Netscape Gecko version.
And I, of course, I picked examples
where Gecko was better, and I showed
them that.
And I asked them to count how
many seconds it took.
Communicator to render some very complex page.
If I think it was 17 seconds,
my machine and it was less than
one second in the other piece of
software.
And this is the power of Open
Source, you know, like everybody was crazy.
It was like a concert of The
Rolling Stones.
I think some of them started breaking
chairs and stuff.
I don't and I see this is
what I want to do when I
grow old.
And it was it was really where
I decided I would go and, and,
and follow the Mozilla project for for
a long time and which I did.
And yeah, I got laid off in
the middle and all of that.
But, yeah, it was something I hang
onto because it was, it was so
cool.
And I felt the impression of what,
you know, people wanted to believe in
open source.
Basically.
I was and it was cool.
That's a great story.
Well, so we should probably that's it.
I think that's a good note to
end on, but before we complete, this,
anything else you want to say about
open source and what it's meant to
you, or what you want to do
in the future, anything you'd like to
say.
Well, something I did not understand as
a kid between proprietary software, I could
steal or copy illegal copy and an
open source.
Is that there's a huge difference.
I didn't get it at the time
and now maybe because I have gray
hair, I get it.
And I think we're in 2021 and
there is software and pretty much everything
we touch, and which is very different
from [19]96 when I started making web
pages.
It's very different from [19]90 or 91.
When I started writing my first program
in basic.
Now, there is software everywhere.
And if I want to be free
as a citizen, then I need free
software.
Because the guy who controls the software,
kind of more or less controls my
life decides.
Whether my, you know, garage door is
going to open or not.
Whether my thermostat is going to work
or not, whether my personal data of
whether I'm in or out of the
house is, shared or not and many,
many different things in my life.
Some of them being very intimate.
Can be shared or not.
And if I want to have control
over that or have someone, I trust
control, have control over there.
I need free software.
That's a, that's a wonderful comment.
Well, so let's let's end.
I just wanted to thank you this
great talking to you.
I loved hearing the stories about the
early days of Netscape and Mozilla project.
That's that's terrific.
Thank you so much.
So very much.
It's it was a pleasure.
Thank you very much.